pop
[Musique]
je
je crois pas mon futur du choc entre je
suis d'abord catholiques pratiquants on
croit en dieu et non sorcellerie mais à
côté de ça il y a quand même des choses
qui paraissent bizarres et dont on ne
voudrait pas croire mais sur ce livre
difficile de délimiter la foi chrétienne
et 7 croyances païennes ça ce pouvoir
magique de certaines personnes est en
fait si on réfléchit bien ce pouvoir
n'existe pas c'est les gens eux-mêmes ce
qu'ils imaginent et le donne à quelqu'un
on dit que vous avez quelques talents de
guérisseur est ce que c'est vrai dit
rien c'est très bien les gens le disent
ça génial pour moi oui c'était ses
secrets ça où on ne peut pas en parler
de ces choses
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de même il vous est arrivé quelque chose
il faut le dire vous êtes sous une
influence néfaste comme on dit il faut
le dire écoutez fait un effort je vous
promets je vous assure qu'on va vous
mettre en silhouette comme on dit dans
notre métier on ne vous reconnaîtra pas
[Musique]
voilà qui donne le ton de ce reportage
la méfiance la peur du le plus souvent à
l'imagination alors on se tait la nuit
dernière la chouette à crier trois fois
ce n'est pas normal il y a du mal un là
dessous
on fermerait raconté que son père harry
avait été un grand moment et il
rencontre le sorcier en route il monte
tranquillement après la route ou un
chemin je me suis pas si c'est une route
un chemin et il faisait chaud ce fou et
ça le soit également
son père de mon grand-père était comme
ça et de sorciers de dire si on était
dans le village on voir et bien quelque
chose que je crève de choix on verra dit
on passera pas soif
alors quand ils ont été un peu plus haut
il y avait un gros rocher il sort son
couteau il puis qui le rocher et puis
mais certains bars de soude alors un
gentil comment après un tonneau le
lendemain le sorcier a été payée habité
d'un g
une aubergiste qui l'avait pas dit que
je viens du pays une météo et que je
t'ai vu attendre
[Musique]
il n'y a plus de 20 ans que je tourne
autour du massif du sancy et il m'est
arrivé justement de toucher du doigt de
constater que quelquefois les gens
croyaient un peu sorcier aux jouteurs de
sort
cela tient à quoi cela tient peut-être à
l'isolément de la région pendant d hiver
très long
les gens restent là repliés sur eux
mêmes ils ont à lutter aussi contre le
climat la neige ceci maintenant n'existe
plus et puis ça vient aussi de cette
rudesse de montagne le soir avant la
traite ceux qui ont assisté à la
cérémonie saint-blaise vont donc aller
table traces avec le cierge béni une
croix à la poutre maîtresse de l'établé
ensuite parce verse quelques gouttes de
cire du cierge béni sur la croupe des
des vaches et donne en même temps un peu
de sel un peu de pain un c vhc bête
persuadé que saint blaise va protéger
les vaches durant l'année contre les
maladies peut-être aussi contre les
jeteurs de sorts
[Musique]
il ya des gens qui jettent des sorts
c'est vrai c'est ça existe ça n'existe
pas à votre avis vous avez déjà entendu
parler de ça on aubert ou poissy eaux de
surface est plus à ça c'est plus dans le
temps mais est ce que vous y croyez vous
dans le temps lorsque lorsqu'on vous
disais cela va même se touchent vous
croyez ce que vous voyez les gens vivent
avec des chansons et la finance et vous
vous n'avez jamais vu ce genre de choses
il y en eu peur votre femme nous a dit
aux plus grands on m'a jeté un sort
voilà alors votre femme ali crois donc
alors jamais été pris alors qu'est-ce
que qu'est ce que vous avez fait
qu'est ce que vous avez fait pour la
persuader du contraire et moi d'y
réussir a vendu mais vous savez il c'est
pas vrai je suis d'humeur et supprimer
médias qui voyait rêver favelas prend à
bon qu'est ce que vous avez fait lady
contours en rien du tout mais le talent
on croit que pense en ce sens ce n'est
pas vous pouvez bien déroulé mars et
c'est le philtre d'amour et sans doute
oui oui madame vous êtes tout
rougissante là comme autant de votre
jeunesse lorsque lorsque votre mari est
venu vous demander en mariage mais c'est
vrai que vous lui avez dit qu'il vous
avait jeté un sort regardez moi madame
parlait pas parler moi regardez moi
c'est vrai et vous en étiez perçu des
plus d'une fois et vous en étiez
persuadé ou bien c'était pour rire c'est
pas
[Musique]
on dit que l'on n'y crois pas alors
qu'on ne cesse d'en être inquiété sur
les faibles les esprits forts ont toute
l'emprise désirer c'est cela la
sorcellerie en auvergne c'est aussi une
affaire de gros sous de vengeance
personnelle de haine qui vient de loin
de très loin
[Musique]
une personne ou qui aimeraient avoir
beaucoup et qui voit son voisin qui
prospère plus que lui alors là il fait
il tente certaines choses on prétend on
prétend qu'ils tentent certaines choses
bien en vie se venge sur des murs des
bêtes voyez pas empêché la prospérité en
mai gagnait rien moi c'était pas ça
parties n'avaient rien à voir je me suis
brûlé à l'âge de 2 12 14 avec de la
poudre la poudre de mines j'avais la
cigarette et je peux passer à fumer
voyez alors j'ai pas fait attention il
est tombé 1
une étincelle alors j'ai eu le temps de
fermer les yeux heureusement j'ai brûlé
la moitié la figure et puis cette
maladroite
alors tous les cheveux tout tout est
tombé bien sûr et il a fallu aller voir
le toubib le médecin médecin militaire à
ce moment là et pas de voiture et a été
voir le docteur lui est bien en passant
dans le village de boissière je peux
bien vous dire le village il y avait une
bonne femme et la levée le feu eh bien
je souffrais terriblement puis à et des
ploucs de france clôt par tout le film
est bien aimable et elle a fait ce qu'il
avait à faire et puis elle a dit vous
sont offertes en faire dix minutes ça a
était véridique au rocher brûlée par un
descendant avec le cheval la douleur
c'est un pays apaisé et puis tout se
dérègle
je sentais si les cloches qui me
diraient les pauvres mais la douleur
était fini alors là j'y vois
[Musique]
on la maison était hanté n'y a plus
moyen de rester dans la maison la nuit
des meubles qui craquent l'escalier
craquer il y avait des bruits de chaînes
par tout ce raffut mais avait des bruits
pour rentable mais j'en devenais fou
c'est sa durée et sa durée et moi et
c'était presque toutes les nuits
alors pour une fois deux fois que
conduisait le vent c'est autre chose
c'est ce qu'on a observé ces des idées
qu'on se fait mais nous
actuellement des gens peuvent encore
jeter des sorts
[Musique]